audi has hit the road with a new tt
though it's now in its third generation
it still features the trademark roofline
and flared wheel arches
there's also an automatic rear spoiler
which rises at speeds above 120
kilometers an hour it provides
additional downward force on the rear
axle
our car tester klaus neatsfit says the
new tt bears a lot of resemblance to the
audi r8 that's certainly deliberate a
way to establish the tt sporty pedigree
the 2.0 liter tfsi engine pumps out
about 169 horsepower and consumes 6.3
liters over 100 kilometers in germany
the base model sells for just over 37
000
what euros really loves is the virtual
cockpit the graphics are incredibly high
definition the display is powered by a
lightning fast computer that performs
more than 8 billion computing operations
per second
compare that to the apollo lunar landing
module which processed some 40 000
operations a second
there's a control right here which lets
you switch to the telephone menu listen
to music or take a look at some other
things
another push and you switch back to the
map
and it's all adjustable
push on the view button and you can
increase or decrease the size of the
speedometer and rpm
view
gauge
or climate
now we'll go for even more oomph the
next generation top of the line tts it
delivers about 228 horsepower 59 more
than the regular tt
that performance boost commands a
premium price 49 000 euros and up in
germany that gets you more than a third
letter on the rear
you also get an electronic control
system that can send power to the rear
wheels the tts only comes as a quattro
we're at the ascari race resort circuit
in southern spain it features the
combination of curves you'll see at many
racetracks around the world the handling
is extremely precise when you take a
curve it responds immediately now we're
moving into a hairpin turn
they're tricky because it's pretty easy
to lose control
but the tts handles it beautifully
perfect
that perfection extends to the
transmission the six-speed s-tronic dual
clutch is identical to volkswagen's dsg
it's precise and shifts through all six
gears lightning fast with no noticeable
interruption of power
that makes for a very smooth
acceleration indeed
klaus says it revs up to the red line of
about 6 800 rpm and then it's time to
shift so this s-tronic 6-speed
transmission is perfectly calibrated to
the engine
now for a few final curves it's too bad
the test is done
but which tt should you go for
is the straight tt good enough
or do you really need the souped up tts
some truth klaus says the regular tt
offers plenty of driving enjoyment and
it's fast too but if you're willing to
shell out a little extra the tts has an
excellent four-wheel drive it's quicker
and a blast to drive
the intermont motorcycle fair is
celebrating its 50th anniversary and bmw
motorrad was there with three world
premieres a roadster a sport tour and a
super sports bike
bmw's motorola stefan schaller says road
safety was the main theme this year and
that's also the focus of these three
premieres
first up the roadster r1200r it's a
snappy performer with an equally
appealing design
edgar heinrich says bmw wanted the bike
to be brawny in front and light and
short in the back that meant using the
regular engine but leaving out the tele
lever front end the front is very narrow
and the cooler is fitted behind the fork
making for that brawny look
their second premiere a touring machine
and because the r 1200 rs also packs a
punch bmw is calling it a sports tourer
the 1200 rs is the sports tour the
sportier bike in bmw's touring lineup
and it's great fun to ride the boxer
engine half shell fairing and seating
position make for a comfortable long
distance ride but it also offers
excellent safety and advanced chassis
technology
and last but not least the star the
sporty s-1000rr
says it's now listed with 199 horsepower
most of the time the testers will get a
bit more out of the bike than you'll see
later on the road it's also 4.5 kilos
lighter and other new features that made
an athletic bike even sportier
in germany bmw currently commands about
25 of the market making the bavarians
the market leader
reason enough for bmw to launch its new
urban mobility strategy
in the growing cities of the future
we'll see more and more two-wheelers on
the road
one italian manufacturer saw that
happening decades ago and even today the
vespa is still a legend though nowadays
piaggio has competition the vespa is
still a cold favorite it's also been
discovered by a new generation of young
urbanites who are turning their backs on
car ownership
but it's not all two wheelers quadro is
also here with their scooter which has
two wheels in front they say it offers
more stability and security
says that the advantage is that two
wheels in front give you more contact
with the road that helps prevent
slippage or skids at the front that
won't happen with two wheels
so a less experienced driver will feel
much safer on the road and the bike will
be a lot more stable in the curves
there's something for just about
everyone at intermont europe's largest
motorcycle publication let readers pick
their favorite motorbike one contender
austrian manufacturer ktm with its 1290
super duke r
and then there's ducati of course
the ducati 916 is an icon a motorcycle
designed as a pure sports machine you
either love it or hate it for its
refusal to compromise but indifference
isn't an option
but it was a true classic that took top
honors the honda 754's combination of
technology performance good looks and
moderate price has made it the dream a
motorcycle owners the world over it's
got fans everywhere from the us to asia
to europe
the city of lights hosted the paris
motor show until october 19th volkswagen
presented its sports version of the fuel
efficient xl1 the concept car is powered
by a 147 kilowatt two-cylinder engine by
ducati a motorcycle engine that's only
slightly modified
it has a top speed rated at 270
kilometers per hour and revs up to 11
000 rpms
infiniti unveiled an extraordinary
concept car at the paris motor show the
5 meter long q80 inspiration a luxury
sedan with rear hinge doors in the back
which open to reveal four bucket seats
and the concept's premium ambitions its
hybrid powertrain puts out 558
horsepower while sipping just five and a
half liters of fuel per hundred
kilometers but there's no saying whether
infinity will produce a road going
version
notes that kids may need playgrounds but
their parents need the mobility to get
them there
car makers are well aware of that and
they design models especially for this
target group
seatt's offering is the toledo
its small starting price and roominess
make it attractive to families he's
going to find out if it can meet the
expectations
with family or without whether visiting
the grandparents or hitting the road for
a far away holiday spot the first thing
is to get where you're going smoothly
comfortably and above all safely
fine tuned sports car performance is not
what the toledo was designed for but it
still handles nimbly and responsively
judges the toledo's handling as suitable
for family driving in other words quite
neutral he has no real complaints he
would have liked more than a five-speed
transmission but the car maker had to
cut corners somewhere
before you can chauffeur the kids all
over town you have to get them into the
car so mata's found a way to test how
easy it is to get in and out of the
toledo
he says an important point for its
family suitability is how well everyone
fits into the car's interior families
with very young children for instance
might need to use an infant car seat it
can be secured here in the back using
the seat belts
that was the belt option
but most new cars nowadays come with
easelfix anchor points built in
these little metal braces which are
generally well hidden allow for the
attachment of compatible seats like
this one
here
other cars may be more easily accessible
and it may be a bit fiddly getting
everything into this one but once the
latch clicks it won't come loose again
and then you can just set the infant
seat on top of that
but if someone's riding in front who
happens to be very big and has to push
the seat all the way back
it can get rather tight
it's not quite as easy to get the baby
seat in or out but it's doable
back on the road we can concentrate on
the engine it's 77 kilowatts take the
toledo from zero to 100 kilometers per
hour in 10.4 seconds
the factory rates fuel consumption at a
thrifty four liters of diesel per
hundred kilometers
the style for you equipment package
including a gps system special paint and
rims pushes the price up to just over 24
000 euros in germany
and the interior
mata scratches the surface and hears
hard plastic all around but then a
family man could see that as desirable
children and messes of every imaginable
kind go together and plastic is easy to
clean
the new toledo presents itself as a
family car for that it may look a bit
aggressive in macho the contours and the
trunk don't quite fit the typical family
car image
so can the toledo make the cut as a true
family car as long as it carries the
kids it probably can
realizes that it's not always about the
kids alone
sometimes they come with accessories
that have to be stowed
often the first advice parents hear when
shopping for a new car is buy a station
wagon but the seat toledo spacious trunk
has no problems taking a whole baby
carriage and whatever groceries or other
provisions might have to go on top
so parents aren't necessarily doomed to
be station wagon drivers
says with a base price of 14 000 euros
the toledo is a good deal for a young
family on a budget but if you'd like a
few extras these smart seats the smart
sat nav the smart stripes on the dash
you're going to have to pay more the
model he tested goes for over 23 000
euros which is nearly half as much again
in the end it's up to the car shopper to
decide whether they need a station wagon
or which options but overall matas is
impressed by what the toledo has to
offer a family
the nsu spider debuted at the 1963
frankfurt motor show
it caused something of a commotion
nsu announced it would start production
within a year where they planned three
to five thousand units annually
loving attention to detail made it an
instant classic the spider listed at an
impressive 8 500 deutsche marks or some
4200 euros
but once the initial uproar had died
down the two-seater convertible was
widely ignored by the german market
after months of delay in september 1964
nsu raffled off the first one off the
assembly line to an employee
the fuel tank and radiator were mounted
in front the engine in back that gave
the engineers an optimal weight
distribution
the engine's small size allowed for a
second trunk space a unique feature at
the time
humming underneath almost like a turbine
was the 50 horsepower wankel engine
armin bowder was assigned to work on the
rotary engine in nsu's r d division he
has fond memories of the project and the
advantages of the rotary concept
in the mid-1950s nsu had already
designed its kkm engine with a static
housing based on felix wonkle's original
dkm rotary engine design in a spinning
housing
but the engine that was to carry the
wonkle name performed noticeably better
the
that the virtue of the wonkle engine
is its smooth circular motion and a
reciprocating piston engine the movement
carries over to the entire vehicle
that was the charm of the rotary engine
you couldn't feel the vibration you just
set out and the engine purred along like
an electric motor
the lower combustion pressure resulted
in more efficient performance plus at
the time reciprocating pistons were
somewhat weaker than they are now that
was another key selling point for the
rotary pistons
and nsu had high hopes for the wonkl
engine
remembers it well the designer suggested
building a roadster with it because the
engine was so small it could be rear
mounted so the car would have trunk
space in front and room for another
storage space over the engine and back
that's the design spider went ahead with
it was the first car that went into
series production with a wankel engine
the engine was extremely high revving
and compared to other small engines very
smooth revolutions above 6000 per minute
were no problem from the mechanical
standpoint but over longer periods the
cooling system couldn't keep up the
spider could run from zero to 100
kilometers per hour in 14 and a half
seconds
unlike the nsu ro80 the spyder had a 500
cc single rotor wankel engine with fuel
consumption rated at 10 liters per
hundred kilometers it all seemed so
promising nsu set out to write
automotive history
but it just didn't work the apex seals
on the combustion chambers kept wearing
out for some time nsu was very obliging
when it came to fixing the many problems
but the car's image suffered
the original goal of 5 000 spiders per
year soon proved utopian in the first
year production nsu sold only 151 units
by comparison 1965 was a good year with
923 sales by the time the production was
halted in 1967 only 2
375 spiders had been sold
today it's a rarity and the fact that
it's the world's first series produced
car with a wankel engine makes the
spider a highly sought after collector's
item
a good conditioned spider will put a
serious dent in your bank account
restoring a spider can easily exceed the
cost of a new car tracking down parts is
like a treasure hunt with no guarantee
you'll ever find what you're looking for
only about 450 spiders still exist today
you